we have hope rebellions are built on
hope have you seen road one yet I've
only seen the trailers and it looks
fantastic
I can't wait yeah yeah because they have
a real advantage being able to go in and
do a one-off story because you don't
have to follow the the trilogy model of
the three act play so they can really
get it done get off and leave the
audience wanting more and they have a
chance to make it their own identity
this one looks like a really gritty
World War two film The Young and the
young out so toka could be more comedic
you know Tom Jones ish about a rogue you
know I mean they have a chance to really
branch out and stake out the territory
for themselves so I'm gonna be forward
to it great by the way Alden Ehrenreich
I met him briefly but I'm sure they pick
the right person it's typical and I you
know I good luck to them I'm sure you'll
be fine but it's you know like like
young Butch and Sundance you know
falling fine Robert Redford and Paul
Newman but you know I have great
confidence in him he's a classmate of my
daughter's from crossroads and she
thinks the world of knowing that he's
very talented
[Music]